all right yeah thanks I'll try not to go
over so we can all so I want to talk
about fairness which we heard a little
bit about yesterday and it certainly you
know beyond differential privacy and
everything I'm going to talk about is
joint work with my colleague Michael
Kern's and our students I use and I
should say that I originally prepared
these slides for like a one-hour 3
seminar that I gave at Columbia last
week I you know went and deleted a lot
of the proofs but all of them but I
don't need to get through all the slides
so definitely like feel free to like ask
hostile questions
midway through so to set the stage and
this is not an audience I need to set
the stage for but as we've been using
machine learning and increasingly
consequential domains it's perhaps not
surprising that there has been a sense
of unease and concern that learning
technologies when placed in parts of
decision-making pipelines where we would
normally expect human decision-makers to
have a burden of moral obligation that
we're sort of worried that these
learning algorithms are violating these
these social norms in particular in this
case that they might be exacerbating
exacerbating sort of human
discrimination or perhaps adding their
own okay so we might be worried that
these machine learning algorithms are
being unfair but as we've come to
realize during this workshop definitions
are tricky ok we can say I think that
something was unfair but if we want to
if we want to go in and fix that if we
want to like embed a notion of fairness
into code then unavoidably we have to
try to be precise about what we mean so
I want to spend the first part of the
talk just going through a little
exercise where we try to like think in a
particular toy situation what we might
mean when we say that something is
unfair ok this is maybe also getting to
another theme that sort of come up in
this workshop as we've talked to folks
who come from different disciplinary
backgrounds the Disciplinary background
I come from sort of values simplified
models not because we believe that this
captures the richness of the human
experience
but because there's sort of value in
modularity ok so I'm gonna think about a
particular scenario in which a lot of
the things that lead to unfairness in
the real world like data quality our
sort of assumed way ok not because I
don't think that these are important but
because I want to sort of focus in on
like one particular kind of cause of
unfairness and think about it carefully
so let me let me show you a a toy
example ok it's a toy and in many
respects obviously a toy and but it sort
of illustrates one way in which
unfairness can creep into a learning
procedure even when it wasn't somehow
directly embedded in the data so imagine
maybe a scenario in which we're doing
college admissions ok we've got a bunch
of students and there's only two things
in this twice an area we can observe
about a student maybe their SAT score
and their GPA and there's something that
we're trying to predict some
well-defined thing we're trying to
predict doesn't matter for the purposes
of the toy example exactly what it is
but you could imagine for example I'm
trying to predict whether they will if
admitted to graduate within five years
with at least a 3.5 GPA and suppose I've
got some historical data to this effect
the positive examples are students who
didn't do that the negative examples are
ones that didn't there of course all
sorts of complications about how I might
have collected data like this and
whether you know I collected it from the
right population whether there was
sample bias but again I want to assume
all of that away for now so I've got the
data this is the data
and there's two populations there's a
green population and there's an orange
population right now I'm just showing
you the green population okay so I want
you to observe a couple of things first
slightly less than half of the green
population is qualified in the sense but
slightly fewer than half of the examples
are pluses rather than minuses and
second there's a pretty good but
imperfect linear decision rule which
separates these two populations so I can
draw a line through space and by and
large the examples above the line are
positive the examples below the line are
negative but not exclusively green
population now I told you there are two
populations so let me show you the other
one the orange population okay and
there's a couple of things you might
notice right away the first maybe is
that there are just fewer orange points
than there are green points the orange
population is a minority and by that I
don't mean anything except that
literally there are fewer of them the
next thing you might notice is that
these points these orange points on this
axis they're sort of uniformly shifted
down and that like they sort of seem to
systematically have lower SAT scores
compared to the green population okay so
example but again you could imagine that
this is for any number of reasons maybe
the green population takes SAT tutoring
classes they take the exam three times
that report only the highest score the
the orange population doesn't they take
it one scold and report that score that
would tend to systematically lower their
SAT scores but look how the aim of the
college the aim of this classification
process is not to admit people with high
SAT scores it is to admit people who
have a positive label and from that
perspective the orange population is
actually better than the green
population more a larger fraction of
them are qualified there's exactly half
positive examples instead of fewer than
half in the green population and it's
even easier to distinguish the positive
examples in the orange population
there's a now a linear decision rule
that makes this distinction perfectly
okay so the orange population from the
point of view of this decision-making
task would seem to be the better
population they're more qualified on
average and they're it's easier to
tell apart the qualified members from
the unqualified members here's the two
populations together and suppose I do
the seemingly reasonable thing I say I
would like to learn the linear decision
rule which minimizes classification
error I'm not gonna I'm not gonna use
race as a feature because I don't want
to inject racial bias okay when I do
that and I feed it into my optimization
algorithm what will come out is the this
decision rule just the one that best
fits the green population it will have
the property that every member of the
orange population is rejected easy to
see why this is the case by the way like
yeah what could I do I could shift down
this decision rule and to better
classify the members of the orange
population that would have the effect of
having worst classification error on the
green population and if I'm minimizing
my average error it's not worth it
because there's more green people and
they therefore contribute more to
average error so somehow the the data
was you know like there was like not
bias embedded in the data I did the
seemingly reasonable thing of learning
the linear decision rule to minimize
classification error and yet despite the
fact that the orange population was
better qualified for the task at hand
they were uniformly rejected seems
unfair
whatever whatever that means in this
process use you know information that's
right useful observation one not
directly related to my talk but like
some toy my often make when I show this
slide is that you could do better
obviously if you allowed me to train a
different a different classifier for the
orange population on the green
population it's a sort of a gut reaction
if I want fairness and machine learning
is that I should not allow the
classifier to make use of race this is
an example where that is it's exactly
reversed you could only be fair maybe we
haven't said what that means by by
allowing the classifier to use race it's
that's a good thing to keep in mind
lesson from a toy example
so let's think about it like okay so I
think hopefully you know like I've
convinced you that like something about
this is unfair whatever unfair means in
this particular example not X not trying
to extrapolate beyond this example let's
think about why we felt this classifier
was unfair and maybe a way to begin
asking that question is to ask the
question who was harmed like who was
harmed by the mistakes made by my
classifier and one reasonable answer is
that the people who were harmed were the
qualified applicants who my classifier
mistakenly rejected like maybe if I like
somehow admitted exactly the people who
were qualified
that would seem okay right someone
someone sort of the people who were
rejected may be called those bummers you
know it's like a bummer but like you
know it was the correct decision but
somehow like maybe the people that we
it's like these orange positive examples
that we viewed that we might view as the
people who were harmed they should have
been admitted and yet we didn't and so
this is one of the things that might
lead you to start thinking about the
false negative rate but if the people
who are harmed are the false negatives
the people who were mistakenly labeled
as negatives who should have been
labeled as positives then perhaps the
false negative rates is somehow getting
at the rates at which harm is being done
sure yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna talk about
like groups and individuals in just a
moment so this might be a way that you
would motivate what has become a very
popular definition of fairness which is
that perhaps like what I might mean by
fairness but the thing that I might
object to in this picture is that the
rate to the fourth negative rate on the
green population is very different than
the false negative rate on the orange
population the false negative rates on
the orange population population is a
hundred percent all qualified applicants
are rejected it's much lower on the
green population this was for example in
the sort of very well publicized
ProPublica article about compass
recidivism prediction the metric that
was used to flag unfairness the false
positive rate had false negative rate in
this in this example of recidivism
prediction was very different between
racial groups okay many other people
have proposed this was a definition of
fairness and more generally this is an
example of a general family of
statistical definitions of fairness
which you can generally you know
manufacture with the following procedure
you partition the world into groups
okay generally according to some
protected attributes like race or gender
then you pick your favorite statistic of
a classifier false positive rate false
negative rate positive predictive value
there's dozens of these and then you say
that the statistic should be
approximately equalized across groups
there's a lot of definitions of this and
if you think about it these statistical
definitions of fairness although they
have some very nice things in it they're
extremely easy to check and they're
actionable they're just constraints on
statistical properties or maybe not
quite what we wanted and let me again
try to convince you of this with a with
a toy example obviously a cartoon but
something that does that does manifest
itself in real data when you train
classifiers with these constraints ok so
imagine we've got a you know medical
world in which we've got gender male and
female and race blue and
and I decide I want to protect both so I
would like to equalize false negative
rates across blue people and green
people and men and women and suppose the
thing I'm trying to predict like whether
you're qualified for college one
classifier which satisfies these
constraints as I will admit everyone to
college if they happen to be a blue man
or a green woman but if you happen to be
a green man or or a blue woman I will
admit you with probability zero okay
this does equalize false negative rates
across the rows and columns okay but
it's cold comfort if you happen to be a
blue woman okay so this is the cartoon
similar things happen on data when you
when you try to apply these sort of
algorithms from the fair machine
learning literature and and maybe it's
like pointing at perhaps that these
statistical fairness definitions weren't
getting at exactly what we meant even
though maybe we were concerned about
false negatives okay the problem is like
when you you know like maybe like the
problem with equalizing the false
negative rates is not with the word
false negative okay we might feel in
certain situations that it's the fault
negatives who are harmed the problem is
with the word rate okay so when we've
been saying false negative rates the
word rate has really meant an average
over a population okay and so a promise
the promise if I if I say that my
classifier is equalizing false negative
rates what it promises you is nothing
unless you go through the photic celeste
you imagine yourself to be a uniformly
random member of your population okay if
you happen to know something else about
yourself like you know both your race
and your gender what the cartoon showed
us is that it might really promise you
nothing so okay so I want to like you
know go through the thought exercise of
like maybe like we'll stick with the
definition and I want to like equalize
false negative rates I like the word
false negative and I want to rethink
what the word rate should mean there's a
couple of things you might imagine the
word rate should mean
okay one from sort of yeah we thought
about a little while ago is like maybe
what false negative rate should mean
what rate should mean is not an average
over the population because that's not a
promise to you maybe what false negative
rate should mean is purely over the
randomness of the classifier this would
be a definition more in the spirit of
differential privacy so maybe something
that said look the false negative rate
on me should be equal to the false
negative rate on Stephen okay
which would mean since the only people
who can be false negatives are the
people who truly have label positive
that for any two individuals we no
longer have to specify groups for any
two individuals who are both positive or
both qualified for college in our
example the chance over the randomness
of the decision-making procedure that
they're rejected from college should be
the same okay the false negative rates
are gonna be the same on me and Steven
this is what I would call a kind of
individual fairness it's not the metric
fairness we've heard a lot about but
it's a different kind of individual
fairness in that the constraint is
enunciated on pairs of individuals it's
a promise made to individuals and it's
something we studied in a paper back in
2016 but there's a this is somehow too
much to ask for
like we were able to under strong
assumptions about what the data
distribution looked like in stylized
settings to do something non-trivial
under this definition but you know if
you're not willing to make those
assumptions then it's not too hard to
see that you know like there's nothing
non-trivial you can do while satisfying
a definition like this essentially
because if I have substantial
uncertainty about what an individual's
label might be as I will inevitably in a
real situation this is gonna tie my
hands too much so I think about a
different thing that rate might mean and
I want to hypothesize that certainly in
not all situations but in some
situations individuals might be subject
to more than one classification task so
for example you're applying to college
it might be that you apply not just to
one college but you apply to many
colleges each of
she's a different admissions rule it
might be that in an online advertising
setting you're over the course of a
month say you are shown not just one
targeted ad but thousands of targeted
ads and so I want to take advantage of
that and so here's like the idea I want
to explicitly postulate not just a
distribution over individuals as a
standard and the machine learning
literature but explicitly a distribution
over problems as well every individual
will be subject to a number of
classification tasks those tasks so
themselves drawn from a distribution and
what I'd like to do now is find not just
a single classifier not just a solution
to a single classification task but a
mapping from problems to classifier it's
a way in which given a new task I can
come up with a new classifier so that I
can promise for example that the false
negative rate is equalized across people
so again I don't want to define groups
anymore I want to say the false negative
rate for me is the same as the false
negative rate for Katrina and I have to
redefine rate rate no longer means an
average over people that wouldn't make
sense if I'm promising list individuals
right no longer means only over the
randomness of the classifier although I
will allow the randomness of the
classifier to be the rate what I mean
now primarily is over the randomness of
the problem sample from the distribution
okay so if you are subject to many
classification tasks this would mean for
example the fraction of the time that I
am harmed by the classifier in the sense
of being a false negative is not
substantially larger for me than it is
for anyone else
this is again an individual definition
of fairness in the sense that it is a
constraint binding on individuals that's
reflected in the label so again I'm not
asking that I'm accepted to the same
number of universities as Katrina I'm
asking that when I'm qualified right the
probability that I am qualified but
rejected should be the same for both of
us the fact that Katrina isn't far more
talented than me is it is something that
is allowed like that is a good
justification for having more success
that's captured in the definition I'm
proposing so I haven't told you what the
model is if you can save your hostel
question until I've shown you the model
in particular maybe it's fine that
somebody who is extraordinarily well
qualified always gets accepted whereas
somebody who's qualified but not nearly
as much so never gets accepted
so you're just objecting to like the
setting in which there are a binary
labels you could you could certainly
imagine talking about this in a setting
with more complicated labels but that's
not binary labels are not fundamental to
this construction but it is the case
that in this talk I'm gonna yes it's not
just that it's it's that we're using the
same labels to talk about fairness as
we're using to talk about the types of
the people so I so it's certainly the
case that you have situations in which
you do not want the fairness metric to
be aligned with the labels
I think sometimes they are so yeah save
you from the next slide you are also
assuming that across the different
classification models they all they sort
of no priors on which labels should be
treated in which way right I mean it's
all basically discovery of the data
you're not you're not imposing any
restrictions on this category always
needs to be I mean there's no
deterministic all I'm asking for
and it's is that false negative rate
should be equalized
this is sounds when I say it sounds very
similar to what many people ask for when
they say fairness including my article
but I'm doing so with a with a different
thing that I'm averaging over which
allows me to talk about individuals or
other than groups
so I I'm not gonna have time to get
through most of it but let me like just
for those Indian you know yeah like
reading math tell me tell you what the
model is and then I'll skip ahead and
tell you what the theorems are okay so
we postulate as usual in machine
learning and unknown distribution over
individuals distribution over features
and now also an unknown distribution
over problems what is a problem it's
just some function mapping features of
individuals to labels okay and we're
gonna learn over some hypothesis class
which is also a function mapping
individuals to labels and I'm not
assuming that the true labels have any
nice structure this is what would be
called agnostic learning if you're a
theoretical computer scientist or
justice machine learning if you weren't
which just means that there's no
assumption that the functions that are
like that these sort of unknown
functions which like define the ground
truth are in the class that I'm learning
over and our task is to find somehow a
mapping from problems to hypotheses so
given a new problem I need to figure out
what my hypothesis will be for
classifying under that problem and what
does it mean to see a new problem well
obviously I can't tell you this function
f that would be what would that be
modeling instead like when you see a new
problem the way I imagine that being
represented to you is that on your
training data of individuals you see a
new vector of labels you see how the
individuals in your training set are
labeled under the new problem
oh so it's false positive rates and
false negative rates are complicated
let's just think about error rates but
you could do all of this with false
negative rates we can define the error
rates on an individual okay this is just
the probability that they are
misclassified in expectation over a draw
of a new problem from the problem
distribution the overall miss
classification rate is just the
expectation of the individual miss
classification rate over a draw from a
person and with that notation in mind we
can define our benchmark the thing we'd
like to achieve we would like to find a
mapping from problems to classifiers
that minimizes our average error subject
to the constraint that for example for
every individual the error of that
individual is the same a data set will
have you know the thing we'll have to
work with is a a data set which is just
a set of n individuals sampled from the
individual distribution and a set of M
problem sampled from the problem
distribution so it's just a represented
as a you know table with n people and
feature vectors and for each of them we
have M labels corresponding to each of
the M problems
so blah blah blah you know blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah okay
so so there's an opportunity there are
two problems we need to think about
there's an optimization problem like how
do I actually computationally find the
solution of this sort and there's a
generalization problem if I find a
solution that has the properties I want
in sample how do we do it out-of-sample
first theorem is that the optimization
problem is solvable if you can solve
learning problems absent this fairness
constraint which believes that you can
learn linear separators you can also
learn linear separators subject to these
individual fairness constraints okay
then there's the question of
generalization which is you know in
order to even think about generalization
we have to like describe what this
object is that map's new problems to
hypotheses but that comes out of the
algorithm which I didn't have time to
show you so you know forget that what I
want to like mention is that the
generalization question is a little more
nuanced than we normally think because
we now need to generalize in two
directions right our dataset consists of
n individuals and M problems and what we
guarantee in sample is that we've found
the classifier that minimizes our error
in sample such that for these particular
end people their error the error rate
for those people is approximately equal
for these particular M problems but we
want to be able to offer a promise to
new people we haven't seen before
and we want that promise to refer to new
problems we haven't seen before and so
ultimately we want to promise that if we
were to go in both of these directions
simultaneously sample an entirely new
data set and an entirely new set of
problems that if we applied the rule we
learned mapping problems to solutions
that we would satisfy our fairness
here as well and be approximately
optimal there as well well you can do
that assuming that the number of
problems you sample is sufficiently
large you know not that large polynomial
and all of the things you care about and
the number of people you sample is
sufficiently large then if you solve
this in sample problem you've also
solved the out-of-sample problem yeah I
didn't get a chance to tell you the form
of this function Phi which is sort of
important to understanding this and we
can talk about it later but yes the
object output by the algorithm is like a
little bit non-obvious
it's represented by the dual variables
for the erm problem you don't have to
you could you don't have to define the
average error rate or average false
positive rate in an unweighted fashion
you would have to you would have to
commit to some definition yes and and
you okay well like putting but let me
just end up here
paper should be online soon I hope you
read it and let me shamelessly plug a
book we Michael Kern's and I have a book
coming out in October it's called the
ethical algorithm and it'll cover a lot
of the issues that we have talked about
at this workshop privacy and fairness
and the tension between formalization
and ethical norms
[Applause]